hi I'm Annie whoo and I'm a mathematics
teacher when I was at school I loved the
humanities English history and drama
they were my best subjects the one I had
a natural affinity for and so
mathematics I studied but didn't really
enjoy or have any insight or particular
appreciation of it it was when I arrived
at University with the intent to become
an English and history teacher and there
was a professor who told me there's this
huge shortage of mathematics teachers
this is an area of need you did a fair
bit of mathematics in school would you
consider changing your area and becoming
a mathematics teacher instead of English
and history where at the time we had
plenty of those and so it was a very
watershed moment for me and that was
what sent me down the rabbit hole of
discovering what the subject was really
about and I've been delighted to
discover how elegant and beautiful it
really is over the last 10 15 years and
that's what I really want everyone
around me to discover
[Music]